हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल गुड इवनिंग
टू ऑल
तो प्लीज सबसे पहले चैट में मुझे यह बताइए
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
ओके वेरी गुड। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है। तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं फिर
स्टूडेंट्स का।
देयर आर टोटल ओनली सिक्स टू ए स्टूडेंट
ओनली थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं तो फिर सेशन
को स्टार्ट करते तब तक के लिए किसी को कोई
डाउट है कोई सवाल है मुझसे रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास रिलेटेड टू द साइबर सिक्योरिटी
कोई कुछ पूछना चाहता है मुझसे
कोई भी कुछ पूछना चाहता है
आज कुछ नए स्टूडेंट्स देखने को मिल रहे
हैं। किसकी फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास है आज?
कितने लोग आज फर्स्ट टाइम आए हैं क्लास
में?
जिनकी आज पहली क्लास है।
जी राधे बोलिए।
हेलो।
ओके। यू आर सेकंड। लास्ट क्लास में एंजॉय
किया। अच्छा लगा?
अगर आपको लास्ट क्लास अच्छी लगे तो फिर आप
लोग कमेंट भी नहीं करते। कमेंट में बताते
भी नहीं क्योंकि जब तक आप कमेंट नहीं
करोगे चाहे पॉजिटिव हो, नेगेटिव हो। बाकी
लोगों को कैसे पता चलेगा? क्योंकि कमेंट
तो आता ही नहीं।
या जगत गुरु जी मैं समझ गया क्योंकि
मंडे टू फ्राइडे के बीच में अगर क्लासेस
मुझे लेनी भी पड़ेंग तो मेरा टाइमिंग यही
है। इसी टाइम पर ही ले सकता हूं मैं 8:15
या 8:30 या 8 ओ क्लॉक अदरवाइज सैटरडे और
संडे क्लासेस होंगी तो वो इसी वो होंगी
आपके स्टैंडर्ड टाइम पर आपका स्टैंडर्ड
टाइम क्या है? आपका है 7:30
अंडरस्टुड? क्योंकि
इस टाइम पर मुझे मुझे टाइम ही यही मिलता
है। मंडे टू फ्राइडे के बीच में मेरा
स्टैंडर्ड टाइम यही है कि मेरे को इतना ही
टाइम मिलता है।
ओके
अच्छी बात है। आप मेरे को फॉलो करने लग गए
तो
बहुत अच्छी बात है। आप अगर फॉलो कर रहे हो
क्योंकि आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा।
एक प्रीमियम कोर्स की क्वालिटी यहां पर
आपको देखने को मिलेगी।
मोहम्मद यह कोर्स बेसिक टू इंटरमीडिएट है
और एडवांस पर हम धीरे-धीरे शिफ्ट कर
जाएंगे। डोंट वरी।
एडवांस में हम शिफ्ट कर जाएंगे। डोंट वरी।
धीरे-धीरे कर जाएंगे। चलो फिर सेशन को
स्टार्ट करते हैं। ओके? तो सेशन को
स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं। अच्छी अच्छा रहेगा।
अदरवाइज
फिर आप लोग चले जाओगे सेशन को छोड़ के।
मुझे पता है।
चलिए फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं। आज हम दो
स्पेसिफिक टर्म के बारे में बात करने वाले
हैं या दो स्पेसिफिक टर्म को हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? कवर करने वाले हैं। अह दैट इज
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन। दैट इज
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेप वेपनाइजेशन। तो
चलो स्टार्ट करते हैं। इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट
ऑफ रेड टीमिंग एंड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग।
एक मिनट मैं ऑन कर लेता हूं। ये रहा ना।
इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ रेड टीमिंग एंड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
एंड वेपनाइजेशन आर टू क्रूशियल फेजेस दैट
अकर्स ड्यूरिंग द लाइफ साइकिल ऑफ एन अटैक
और पेन टेस्ट। मतलब रेड टिमिंग और
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की पूरी लाइफ साइकिल
में शुरुआत से लेकर खत्म होने तक के सफर
में यह दोनों फेजेस सबसे क्रिटिकल और
इंपॉर्टेंट फेजेस में से एक हैं। क्योंकि
यह आपके अटैक शुरू होने से पहले ठीक जब भी
आपका अटैक शुरू होता है अटैक का अटैक का
जो भी आपका एग्जीक्यूशन फेज होता है उससे
जस्ट पहले स्टार्ट होते हैं। और मतलब आप
यह बोल सकते हो कि इन दोनों स्टेप्स के
बिना एक रियल वर्ल्ड साइबर अटैक या रेड
टीम ऑपरेशन पॉसिबल नहीं है। हम कहें तो
अगर आपको कोई भी एक रियल वर्ल्ड अटैक
परफॉर्म करना है या कोई भी आपको एक रेड
टीम ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करना है तो इन दोनों
अटैक के बिग बगैर वो पॉसिबल नहीं है। तो
जैसा कि आप सबको पता है प्रीवियस क्लासेस
में हमने पढ़ा था कि एक अटैक का पूरा फ्लो
क्या होता है? सबसे पहला होता है
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग। सबसे पहला कौन सा
फ्लो होता है आपका? इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग
जिसमें आप क्या करते हो इंफॉर्मेशन को
कलेक्ट करते हो उसके बाद होता है आपका
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन गैदरिंग के बाद आप क्या
करते हो सेटअप करते हो उस इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
को वेरीफाई करते हो वेरीफाई करके अरेंज
करते हो अरेंज करने के बाद मतलब क्या करते
हो उसके लिए रिसोर्स डेवलप करते हो उसके
लिए एक्सप्लइट लिखते हो कोई टूल परचेस
करना टूल परचेस करते हो कोई वनविटीज
खरीदनी है वनविटीज खरीदने हो खरीदते हो या
कोई वनविटीज फाइंड आउट करते हो जो भी है
आप क्या करते हो एक रेस
डेवलप करते हैं। उसके बाद उसको क्या करते
हो? वेपनाइज करते हो। जब आपको पता चल गया
आपके पास सॉलिड इंफॉर्मेशन है। आपने एक
पेलोड बनाया उसको फिर उसके टारगेट के
अकॉर्डिंग उसको वेपनाइज करते हो। उसको
टारगेट के अकॉर्डिंग डिजाइन करते हो। देन
उसके बाद जब आपने उसको क्या कर लिया कि एक
बार इंफॉर्मेशनेशन कलेक्ट कर ली। उस
रिसोर्सेज का डेवलपमेंट कर लिया।
रिसोर्सेज को डेवलप कर लिया। आपने क्या कर
लिया? उसको उसके लिए एक सेटअप रेडी कर
लिया। इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेडी कर ली। उसके
बाद उसका एक एक्स परफेक्ट वर्किंग
एक्सप्लइट क्रिएट कर लिया। बना लिया,
वेपनाइज कर लिया। फिर उसको नेक्स्ट बारी
आती है आपकी उसको डिलीवर करने की। क्या?
नेक्स्ट बारी आती है आपकी उसको डिलीवर
करने की। फिर उसको आप उसको डिलीवर करते हो
और डिलीवर के बाद क्या होता है आपका
एग्जीक्यूशन। यह कुछ कॉमन लाइफ साइकिल है
अटैक की। यह एक कॉमन अटैक लाइफ साइकिल है
किसकी? उसकी किसी भी एक साइबर अटैक की। और
इस जो कॉमन अटैक लाइफ साइकिल में यह
रिसोर्स ये दोनों टर्म्स जो रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट है और वेपनाइजेशन है। इस पूरी
चैन का सबसे मजबूत कड़िया है। अब आप
इमेजिन करोगे अगर आप सोच के देखोगे कि अगर
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट हटा दूं इस चेन में से
एक चैन है। इस चेन में से रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट हटा दूं और वेपनाइजेशन हटा दूं।
तो क्या बताओ जब चेन ब्रेक ही हो जाएगी जब
इसमें कड़ियां जुड़ ही नहीं रही
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के बाद। क्या अटैक
एग्जीक्यूट हो पाएगा? अटैक एग्जीक्यूट
नहीं हो पाएगा। मतलब यह है कि इस जो यह
अटैक लाइफ साइकिल की जो चैन है इस चैन की
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और वेपनाइजेशन दो बहुत
बड़ी हैम कड़ियां हैं या दो बहुत बड़ी
मजबूत कड़ियां हैं। ओके समझ में आ गया?
नेक्स्ट
आगे बढ़ने से पहले मैं एक काम करता हूं।
आगे बढ़ने से पहले मैं आप सबके साथ एक बात
क्लियर कर देता हूं। क्योंकि काफी लोग
क्या करते हैं ना रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और
वेपनाइजेशन को सेम समझने की बहुत बड़ी
मिस्टेक करते हैं। बहुत बड़ी गलती करते
हैं। क्योंकि इसका मेन कारण क्या है सेम
समझने का? क्योंकि दोनों ही दोनों ही टर्म
आपका रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट है या आपका
वेपनाइजेशन है वो एग्जीक्यूशन फज़ फज़ से
पहले आते हैं। एग्जीक्यूशन फज़ क्या है
आपका? इधर है। डिलीवरी एंड एक्सप्लॉयटेशन
ये आपका है। इस फज़ से पहले ही क्या आते
आपका रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन।
इसीलिए बहुत सारे लोग क्या करते हैं? इन
दोनों टर्म्स को क्या करते हैं? सेम समझने
की कोशिश करते हैं। बट एज ए रेटिमर आपको
इनके बीच का जो फर्क है, जो डिफरेंस है वो
क्रिस्टल क्लियर होना चाहिए। और
एग्जैक्टली यही कंफ्यूजन क्लियर करने के
लिए हम आज का सेशन क्या कर रहे हैं?
लेने आए हैं। आज का सेशन डिस्कस करने आए
हैं या एग्जजेक्टली यही कंफ्यूजन क्लियर
करने के लिए आपका आज का सेशन रेडी किया
गया है। देखो आगे की क्लासेस में जब भी हम
कोई भी कस्टम केयर अलोड्स मशियस ऑफिस
डॉक्यूमेंट्स या क्लाइंट साइड फेसिंग
अटैचमेंट डेवलप करेंगे तो आपको इन दोनों
टर्म्स के बीच का एग्जैक्ट डिफरेंस और
कनेक्शन समझना मैंडेटरी है। क्यों?
मैंडेटरी क्यों है? क्योंकि जब भी आप क्या
करते हो? जब भी आप कोई भी कस्टम पेलोड
बनाओगे तो आपको क्या सबसे पहले आपको क्या
पता होना चाहिए कि उस पेलोड का कौन सा
हिस्सा आपकी लैब या आपके सर्वर पर कंफिगर
होगा और कौन सा हिस्सा आपका जो टारगेट
मशीन है जो आपका विक्टिम की फाइल है उसमें
पैक किया जाएगा। मतलब सिंपल यह है कि अगर
आपको रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और वेपनाइजेशन की
नॉलेज नहीं होगी तो फिर आप यह डिफरेंशिएट
नहीं कर पाओगे कि आपने जो पेलोड तैयार
किया है उसका कौन सा हिस्सा आपके साइड में
कंफिगर होगा और कौन सा हिस्सा जो टारगेट
एनवायरमेंट है जिसके ऊपर एग्जीक्यूशन होना
है वहां पर पैक होगा या डिलीवर होगा इस
चीज में बहुत बड़ा कंफ्यूजन होगा और दूसरी
बात अगर आपका अटैक फेल हो गया अगर आपका
एक्सप्लइट फेल हो गया तो फिर आपको यह
समझने में भी दिक्कत आएगी कि
जो पेलोड फेल हुआ है जो एक्सप्लइट फेल हुआ
है वो किस साइड से फेल हुआ है क्या वो
कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर की साइड से फेल
हुआ है या आपने जो सेल कोड लिखा था जो
आपने एक्सप्लइट लिखा था उसमें कमी है या
आपके पैकेजिंग में कमी है मतलब आपको यह
पता होना चाहिए कि जो एक्सप्लइट आपने लिखा
अगर वह फेल हुआ तो उसमें किस साइड कमी थी?
ड्यूरिंग पैकेजिंग कमी रही है या फिर आपने
उसको डेवलप किया। डेवलपमेंट साइड में कमी
रही है। और यह डिफरेंशिएट आप तभी कर पाओगे
जब आपको नॉलेज होगी किसकी?
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन की।
आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर पता होना चाहिए ये
दोनों टर्म्स हैं क्या चीज और किस बारे
में। तो सबसे पहले समझते हैं कि ये दोनों
टर्म्स आई कहां से हैं। तो आगे बढ़ने से
पहले सबसे पहले समझते हैं कि ये दोनों
टर्म्स आई कहां से हैं? क्या बात
स्टूडेंट्स? क्लास छोड़ छोड़ के जा रहे
हो? सबको सब आता है।
क्या हुआ? बाकी स्टूडेंट्स कहां गए अचानक
से? सडनली
समझ नहीं आ रहा क्या? बताइए।
समझ में नहीं आया क्या?
बताओ समझ में नहीं आया।
ओके
तो चलिए अब बात करते हैं कि ये दोनों
टर्म्स आई कहां से हैं। ठीक है? द टर्म्स
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन
ओरिजनेटेड इन मिलिट्री स्ट्रेटजी दे हैव
बीन एडप्टेड एंड अपाइड इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी टू डिस्क्राइब द की फेजेस इन
लाइफ साइकिल ऑफ एन साइबर अटैक। मतलब ये
क्या है? दोनों टर्म्स रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
और वेपनाइजेशन ओरिजिनली मिलिट्री
स्ट्रेटजी से ओरिजनेट हुए हैं। जैसे कि
मिलिट्री ऑपरेशंस में क्या होता है? सबसे
पहले रिसोर्सेज बिल्ड किए जाते हैं।
रिसोर्सेज को बाय किया जाता है। उसके बाद
क्या होता है? मिलिट्री ऑपरेशंस में उनको
कंबैट के लिए वेपनाइज किया जाता है।
प्रिपेयर किया जाता है, रेडी किया जाता
है। मतलब अगर उनके पास रिसोर्सेज नहीं
होंगे तो वह क्या नहीं कर पाएंगे? फाइट
नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो इसलिए किसी भी
मिलिट्री ऑपरेशन में सबसे पहली क्या चीज
होती है? रिसोर्सेज को बिल्ड करना।
रिसोर्सेज को अह बाय करना। देन ओनली आप
क्या कर सकते हो? कंबट के लिए तैयारी कर
सकते हो। कंबैट के लिए प्रिपेयर कर सकते
हो। तो साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंडस्ट्री ने भी
इसी कांसेप्ट को अडप्ट किया है और अपनी
साइबर अटैक लाइस साइकिल का हिस्सा बनाया।
लेकिन जब हम मॉडर्न साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फ्रेमवर्क की बात करते हैं। अब मॉडर्न
साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क में दो ही
फ्रेमवर्क पॉपुलर है। सबसे पहला माइटर
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क दूसरा पॉपुलर है साइबर किल
चेन। तो जब भी हम क्या करते हैं? मॉडर्न
साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क की बात करते
हैं तो इन दोनों टर्म्स को अलग-अलग तरीके
से मैप किया गया है। जो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
है उसको अलग तरीके से मैप किया गया है और
वेपनाइजेशन है उसको अलग तरीके से मैप किया
गया है। जो वेपनाइजेशन है आपको साइबर किल
फ्रेमवर्क में साइबर किल चेन फ्रेमवर्क
में देखने को मिलेगा। वहीं पर आपका जो
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट है वो आपको माइटर अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क में देखने को मिलेगा। और अगर
आपको पहले से इन दोनों फ्रेमवर्क की थोड़ी
बहुत भी जानकारी है। अगर आप पहले से इन
दोनों फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में फमिलियर हो
या दोनों फ्रेमवर्क से फमिलियर हो तो आपने
यह दोनों टर्म्स रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और
आपकी वेपनाइजेशन डेफिनेटली सुनी होगी।
क्योंकि दोनों फ्रेमवर्क का काम एक ही है।
अटैक के पूरे प्रोसेस को स्टेप बाय स्टेप
समझाना, स्टेप बाय स्टेप एक्सप्लेन करना।
इसलिए जब भी हम डेली बातचीत की बात करें
तो लोग क्या करते हैं? बिना सोचे समझे
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और वेपनाइजेशन को एक ही
जगह पर एक ही मतलब के लिए यूज करते हैं या
एक ही जगह पर एक ही एक ही जगह पर एक ही
मतलब के लिए इंटरचेंजबली यूज करते हैं।
मतलब लोगों को लगता है कि रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट और वेपनाइजेशन में कोई भी फर्क
नहीं है। लेकिन एज ए प्रोफेशनल रेड टीमर
आपको पता होना चाहिए कि दोनों के बीच में
क्या डिफरेंस है। अब मतलब यह है कि जो
नॉर्मल लोग हैं या जो बिगिनर्स हैं वो
चाहे दोनों फ्रेमवर्क दोनों फेजेस को
दोनों कौन सी टर्म्स है आपके रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट और वेपनाइजेशन को सेम बोलो बोले
लेकिन एक प्रोफेशनल रेड टिमर को इनके बीच
का माइनर डिफरेंस पता होना चाहिए इनके बीच
की जो थिन लाइन है या जो बारीक लाइन है या
जो छोटा सा डिफरेंस है वो वो आपको पता
होना चाहिए। इंडस्ट्री में अक्सर लोग क्या
करते हैं? इन दोनों टर्म्स को आपस में
मिक्स कर देते हैं। लेकिन एक प्रोफेशनल
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट कभी भी इन
दोनों को मिक्स नहीं करता। उसको हमेशा पता
होता है कि जो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट है और
वेपनाइजेशन है उन दोनों में क्या डिफरेंस
है? उन दोनों में क्या डिफरेंस है? वेरी
गुड इवनिंग। तो नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट। नाउ आगे चलते हैं।
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट फोकसेस ऑन एक्वायरिंग
और बिल्डिंग द नेसेसरी रिसोर्सेज फॉर एन
अटैक। व्हाइल वेपनाइजेशन इनवॉल्व्स
टर्निंग दोज़ रिसोर्सेज इनू इफेक्टिव साइबर
वेपंस। मतलब सोचिए आपने अपना रिकॉन फेज
कंप्लीट कर लिया। और आपको टारगेट
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के बारे में काफी सारी
स्ट्रांग इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई। काफी सारी
गहरी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई। जैसे उनके
टेक्नोलॉजी स्टक्स कौन सी यूज़ हो रही है
और जो उनके अंदर जो एंप्लाइजज़ हैं उनके
बारे में काफी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल गई। तो
अब रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट की बात करें तो आप
क्या करते हो? आपने जो रॉ मटेरियल क्या
किया है? कलेक्ट किया है उसको अरेंज करते
हो। जैसे फेसिंग डोमेन बाय करना, एसएसएल
सर्टिफिकेट सेटअप करना, कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
सर्वर डिप्लॉय करना, सेल कोड लिखना,
एक्सप्लइट कोड लिखना, ऑफर स्केशन
स्क्रिप्ट रेडी करना, स्टैंडर्ड ऑफेंसिव
टूल्स को गैदर करना या जो कॉम्प्रोमाइज
क्रेडेंशियल्स है जो डार्क वेबक पर
अवेलेबल्स है जो डाटा लीक्स हैं उनके वैसे
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल नहीं है उनको क्या करना?
परचेस करना। या फिर आप क्या करते हो जो
टारगेट है टारगेट पर्सन की फेक सोशल
मीडिया प्रोफाइल बनाना ये सारी चीजें आप
क्या करते हो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट में करते
हो वहीं पर वेपनाइजेशन में क्या करते हो
अब आपके पास क्या है रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट से
जो सेल कोड है और इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेडी है
तब आप क्या करते हो अब आप उस सेल कोड और
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर का यूज़ करके उनको एक
यूजेबल साइबर वेपन में कंफर्म कर अह वेपन
में कन्वर्ट करते हो जैसे आपने जो सेल कोड
बनाया उसको क्या किया आपने एक ऑफिस वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट में कन्वर्ट किया ऑफिस वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट में क्या किया जो वीबीए मैक है
वीबीए मैक में वीबीए मैक्रो में उसके लिए
एक और कोड लिखा जो क्या करेगा जब भी आप
वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट को ओपन करोगे तो वो वीबीए
मै एग्जीक्यूट होगा और उस एग्जीक्यूट होते
ही जो आपका सेल कोड है वह एग्जीक्यूट होगा
या फिर आपने क्या किया जो आपका मिलेशियस
पेलोड था उसको एक
लेजिट लुकिंग सॉफ्टवेयर इंस्टॉलर के साथ
क्या किया आपने? बिल्ड कर दिया। मतलब एक
कोई भी एक सॉफ्टवेयर था जो बिल्कुल
लेजिट था। बिल्कुल एक वैलिड सॉफ्टवेयर था।
एक सही सॉफ्टवेयर था। मलेशियस सॉफ्टवेयर
नहीं था। तो आपने क्या किया? उसका जो
इंस्टॉलर होता है, कोई भी प्रोग्राम्स आप
क्या करते हो? इंस्टॉल करते हो तो उसके
इंस्टॉलर के साथ आपने अपना पेलोड बाइंड कर
दिया और टारगेट को भेज दिया कि हमारा
अपडेटेड वर्जन है इस पर्टिकुलर सॉफ्टवेयर
का। जैसे क्लाइंट उसको इंस्टॉल करेगा तो
आपका कोड क्या होगा? रिवर्स सेल मिल
जाएगा। आपका कोड एग्जीक्यूट कर जाएगा। तो
मेरा मतलब यह क्या है कि रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट में जो भी रिसोर्सेज थे अपने
रिक्वायरमेंट के हिसाब से क्लाइंट के
रिक्वायरमेंट के हिसाब से आप एक बेहतरीन
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सेटअप करते हो। उसके लिए
चाहे आपको डोमेन खरीदना हो, चाहे उसके लिए
आपको C2 सर्वर्स डेप्लॉय करने हो, उस उसके
लिए स्पेशल खुद से कोई मिलिशियस कोड लिखना
हो या फिर कोई स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी हो, कोई
क्रेडेंशियल परचेस करना हो। ये सारी चीजें
आ गई आपकी रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट के अंदर। और
वेपनाइजेशन में क्या किया हुआ? इन सारी
चीजों को आप क्या करते हो? इन सारी चीजों
को एक वेपन में कन्वर्ट करते हो। उस
पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के हिसाब से उसको
बिल्कुल कन्वर्ट करते हो कि उसके बाद
डायरेक्ट फाइनल एग्जीक्यूशन ही होगा। द टू
टर्म्स नाउ द टू टर्म्स रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
एंड वेपनाइजेशन आर समटाइ्स यूज्ड
इंटरचेंजबली गिवन देवर देयर ओवरलैपिंग
ऑब्जेक्टिव हाउएवर इट इज़ वेरीेंट टू
अंडरस्टैंड द डिस्टिंशन बिटवीन द टू मतलब
यह है ये जो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और जो
वेपनाइजेशन है दोनों का टारगेट एक ही है
अटैक एग्जीक्यूशन से पहले की तैयारी करना
दोनों का टारगेट क्या है चाहे वो रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट है चाहे वेपनाइजेशन है। दोनों
का गोल क्या है कि जो अटैक एग्जीक्यूशन है
उससे पहले की प्रिपरेशन करना। उससे पहले
की तैयारी करना। इसलिए लोग क्या करते हैं?
अक्सर बातोंबातों में इन दोनों टर्म्स को
अलग-अलग बताने की जगह आपस में इंटरचेंज
करके यूज़ करते हैं। लेकिन इन दोनों के बीच
का एग्जैक्ट डिफेक्ट समझना भी एक
इंपॉर्टेंट स्किल है। एक इंपॉर्टेंट
बोल सकते हो आप। बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है। मतलब
लोग चाहे कुछ भी यूज़ बोलते हो, लेकिन एज ए
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट आपको इन दोनों
टर्म्स के बीच का एग्जैक्ट डिफरेंस पता
होना चाहिए कि रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट कहां से
आई और यह क्या चीज है? वेपनाइजेशन कहां से
आई और यह क्या चीज है? इन दोनों का
एग्जैक्ट डिफरेंस आप दोनों को पता होना
चाहिए। नाउ दिस कैन बी डन बाय
अंडरस्टैंडिंग हाउ दीज़ टर्म्स हैव बीन
यूज़्ड एंड इंप्लीमेंटेड इनू मॉडर्न डे
साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेमवर्क्स एंड किल
चेन्स लाइक माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क एंड द
साइबर किल चेन। मतलब और यह फर्क आपको तभी
पता चलेगा। यह फर्क आपको तभी समझ आएगा जब
आप देखोगे कि इन दोनों टर्म्स को अलग-अलग
इंडस्ट्री फ्रेमवर्क्स में कैसे फिट किया
गया है। कैसे यूज किया जाता है। जैसे कि
माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क ने इसको रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट का नाम दिया है। वहीं पर साइबर
किल चेन ने इसको वेपनाइजेशन का नाम दिया
है। तो इन दोनों ने अलग-अलग नाम क्यों यूज़
किया है? क्या ऐसा डिफरेंस है? लेकिन हम
इस टर्म को हमेशा इंटरचेंजबली यूज़ करते
हैं। तो ये डिफरेंस आपको तभी समझ में आएगा
जब आप इन दोनों इंडस्ट्री फ्रेमवर्क में
के बारे में डिस्कस करोगे। बोथ द माइट्रा
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क एंड द साइबर किल चेन आर
वाइडली यूज्ड टेक्निक्स इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एंड दे प्रोवाइड स्ट्रक्चरर्ड
अप्रोच टू अंडरस्टैंडिंग एंड एनालाइजिंग
साइबर थ्रेट। ये जो दोनों फ्रेमवर्क्स
हैं। कौन सा? माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क एंड
द साइबर किल चेन। ठीक है? साइबर किल चेन
दो दोनों के दोनों साइबर सिक्योरिटी
फ्रेमवर्क वर्ल्ड के सबसे पॉपुलर और
स्टैंडर्ड्स मॉडल मॉडल में से एक माने
जाते हैं। क्योंकि क्योंकि किसी भी साइबर
अटैक को स्टेप बाय स्टेप एनालाइज करने के
लिए या स्टेप बाय स्टेप समझने के लिए इन
दोनों फ्रेमवर्क का सहारा लिया जाता है।
किसी भी चाहे वह आपके रेड टिमर्स हो, चाहे
आपका वह ब्लू टिमर्स हो, सभी क्या करते
हैं? इन दोनों फ्रेमवर्क को बिल्कुल ओपनली
यूज़ करते हैं। इसलिए यह क्या है? आपके
रियल वर्ल्ड साइबर सिक्योरिटी फ्रेम में
क्या कहते हैं? एक स्टैंडर्ड मॉडल माने
जाते हैं। तो यहां किसी को पता है कि यह
माइट अटेक फ्रेमवर्क और साइबर गिल चेन
होते क्या है? किसी को पता है?
तो मुझे एक चीज बताओ। सबको समझ में आया
यहां तक? जो मैं समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं। सबको समझ में आ रहा है?
नो क्या हो गया?
नहीं मैं यह बता रहा हूं। अभी जहां अभी तक
मैंने जो भी कुछ डिस्कस किया आप लोगों को
ज्यादा फास्ट तो नहीं हो रहा?
ज्यादा फास्ट हो रहा हो या समझ में आ रहा
है?
समझ आ रहा है?
मतलब आपके ऊपर से तो नहीं गया। बोर तो
नहीं हो गए या कुछ ऐसी चीज?
ओके समझ में आ रहा है?
चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट माइट अटैक फ्रेमवर्क के
बारे में डिस्कस करते हैं। करें डिस्कस
करें डिस्कस।
डिस्कस करें।
ओके। तो नेक्स्ट आपका माइट्रा अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क। तो माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क पे
डिस्कस करने पहले करने से पहले एक चीज जान
लेते हैं। ठीक है? दिस इज नॉट जस्ट ए
फ्रेमवर्क। दिस फ्रेमवर्क इज द बैकबोन ऑफ
आवर ऑफेंसिव एंड डिफेंसिव साइबर
सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशंस। जो माइट्रो अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क है यह कोई आम फ्रेमवर्क नहीं
है। यह फ्रेमवर्क हमारे ऑफेंसिव और
डिफेंसिव साइबर सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशंस की
बैकबोन है। इसीलिए सबसे पहले हम क्या करते
हैं? इस फ्रेमवर्क में डीप ड्राइव करने से
पहले इस फ्रेमवर्क में डीपली जाने से पहले
सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं? इसकी थोड़ी
सी हिस्ट्री के बारे में जानते हैं कि इस
फ्रेमवर्क का इवोल्यूशन क्यों हुआ? यह
फ्रेमवर्क क्यों आया? तो बिफोर द माइटर
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क क्या था? माइटर अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क के आने से पहले क्या होता था?
मार्केट में माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क आने से
पहले भी बड़े-बड़े डेटा ब्रचेस होते थे,
हैक्स होते थे। लेकिन हमारे पास ऐसा कोई
स्टैंडर्डाइज या मीनिंगफुल तरीका नहीं था
जिससे हम क्लासिफाई कर सकें कि
एग्जजेक्टली क्या हुआ था। मतलब मार्केट
में एक पूरा स्ट्रक्चर मिसिंग था। तो
माइटर ने क्या किया? उन्होंने जो पब्लिकली
डिस्क्लोज्ड हैक थे। माइटर ने क्या किया?
जो पब्लिकली डिस्क्लोज्ड हैक थे और जो
डाटा ब्रचेस थे साथ में जो थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस डाटा था उसको उठाया और
उन्होंने क्या किया? जो रियल वर्ल्ड थ्रेट
एक्टर्स थे और जो एपीटी थे उनको उनके उनको
क्या किया? उनके बिहेवियर को एनालाइज
किया। उन्होंने क्या माइटर अटैक ने क्या
जो माइट था उन्होंने क्या किया जो
पब्लिकली डिस्क्लोज्ड हैकस थे जो डाटा
ब्रिजेचेस थे जो थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस रिपोर्ट
थी या जो भी रियल वर्ल्ड थ्रेट एक्टर्स
एक्टर्स या एपीडीज के ग्रुप में जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन अवेलेबल थी उन किस टाइप का
उनका बिहेवियर था उन सबको क्या किया
उन्होंने
उन्होंने डीपली एनालाइज किया एनालाइज करने
के बाद उन्होंने क्या किया उनकी सारी
टेक्निक को एक ग्लोबली एक्सेबल नॉलेज बेस
में कन्वर्ट कर दिया या मैप कर दिया।
जितना भी डाटा अवेलेबल था हैकर्स के ऊपर
उन सबको क्या कर दिया? उनकी जो भी
टेक्निक्स थी उनको ग्लोबली ग्लोबली
एक्सेसबल नॉलेज बेस में मैप कर दिया। मतलब
मैप करके रख दिया कि कौन सा टाइप का हैकर
है। उसका कौन सा ग्रुप है? किस टाइप के वो
टेक्निक यूज़ करता है। किस टाइप के टूल यूज़
करता है। किस टाइप का उसका फॉलो होता है।
यह सारी चीजें क्या कर दी? उसने मैप करके
रख दी एक फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर एक ही जगह पर
और
जो यह फ्रेमवर्क था यह किस लिए बनाया गया
था? यह फ्रेमवर्क इसलिए बनाया गया था ताकि
इंडस्ट्री के लोगों को यह क्रिस्टल क्लियर
हो सके या समझ में आ सके कि हाउ साइबर
अटैक्स आर एक्चुअली परफॉर्म्ड। मतलब उनको
बिल्कुल साफ-साफ समझ में आ सके कि साइबर
अटैक्स कैसे परफॉर्म होते हैं। उनका मेन
पर्पस था कि कैसे साइबर अटैक परफॉर्म होते
हैं उसके बारे में एक सेंट्रलाइज्ड डेटा
प्रोवाइड करना। कैसे कौन सी कमांड
क्या-क्या यूज़ किया जाता है। तो वो सारी
चीजें क्या है? इस फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर मैप
कर दी गई। तो नाउ अभी बात करते हैं माइटर
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क के इंट्रोडक्शन की। द
माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क इज ए ग्लोबली
एक्सेबल नॉलेज बेस ग्लोबली ग्लोबली
एक्सेबल नॉलेज बेस ऑफ एडवाइज़री टैिक्स एंड
टेक्निक्स बेस्ड ऑन रियल वर्ल्ड थ्रेट्स
एंड थ्रेट एक्टर्स इट वाज़ डेवलप्ड टू
इंप्रूव द अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ हाउ साइबर
अटैक्स आर परफॉर्म। जैसा कि अभी हमने
डिस्कस किया कि यह एक वर्ल्ड एक्सेबल
डेटाबेस है जिसे कोई भी एक्सेस कर सकता है
जिसे कोई भी देख सकता है। चाहे ब्लू
ट्यूमर्स हो, रेड ट्यूमर्स हो, कोई भी आप
मैं सब देख सकते हैं जिसमें दुनिया में
जितने भी हैकर्स या अटैकर्स हैं, सबकी
टेिक्स और टेक्निक को मैप किया गया है।
ग्रुप की फॉर्म में कन्वर्ट किया गया है।
ताकि साइबर अटैक कैसे परफॉर्म होते हैं,
उनके बारे में जानकारी प्रोवाइड की जा
सके।
अब इसके अंदर जो एक अटैक टर्म है इसकी एक
फुल फॉर्म है। इसका एक एब्रवेएशन है जिसको
बोलते हैं एडवर्सियल टैिक्स, टेक्निक्स
एंड कॉमन नॉलेज। इसकी फुल फॉर्म क्या है?
एडवर्सियल टैिक्स, टेक्निक्स एंड कॉमन
नॉलेज। द माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क इज टिपिकली
एंप्लॉयड
और यूज्ड एज ए बेसलाइन एंड मॉडल फॉर
एडवर्शियल बिहेवियर। मतलब यह पूरा
फ्रेमवर्क एक इंडस्ट्री बेस लाइन और मॉडल
मॉडल की तरह यूज होता है जो एडवर्सियल
बिहेवियर को हाईलाइट करता है। आई एम
रिपीटिंग अगेन कि जो माइट्रा अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क है वो एक इंडस्ट्री बेस लाइन और
मॉडल की तरह यूज किया जाता है। जो क्या
करता है जो आपका जो एडवर्सियल बिहेवियर है
उसको हाईलाइट करता है। मतलब हाईलाइट द
वेरियस फेजेस ऑफ एडवर्सरी थ्रेट एक्टर
लाइफ साइकिल मतलब कि एक थ्रेट एक्टर का
अटैक लाइफ साइकिल क्या है? थ्रेट एक्टर
कौन है? हैकर।
अटैकर्स ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स जो क्या करते
हैं? हैक करते हैं। ब्लैक हेट हैकर्स।
आपके क्या है? अटैकर्स हैं। हम नहीं हम तो
क्या टेस्टर्स होते हैं पेंटेस्टर्स।
लेकिन
ये थ्रेट थ्रेट अटैकर्स कौन से होते हैं?
जो ब्लैक अटैकर्स होता है। उनका अटैक लाइफ
साइकिल क्या है? उसको क्या करता है? यह
हाईलाइट करता है। व्हाट सॉफ्टवेयर दे
एंप्लॉय? वह कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर या टूल्स
यूज करते हैं एंड द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम दे
टारगेट और किस टाइप का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कौन Windows है, Linux है, Mac OS है या
क्लाउड को टारगेट कर रहे हैं। मतलब यह है
कि जो माइल अटैक फ्रेमवर्क है, यह एक
बेसलाइन की तरह काम करता है। एक बेसलाइन
मॉडल की तरह काम करता है। जो यह हाईलाइट
करता है कि एक पर्टिकुलर थ्रेट एक्टर उसकी
अटैक लाइफ साइकिल क्या है? मतलब कौन-कौन
से स्टेप्स में वो अटैक परफॉर्म करता है
और किस टाइप के ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को क्या करता
है? टारगेट करता है। कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर यूज़
करता है? कौन सा टूल यूज़ करता है? किस
टाइप का ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को टारगेट करता
है? Linux को करता है, Mac OS करता है,
मोबाइल को करते हैं या फिर वो क्लाउड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को करते हैं। हर एक
टारगेट का अपना एक बिहेवियर होता है। वो
सारा बिहेवियर क्या करता है? यह माइटर
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क मैप करके रखता है। एंड
नेक्स्ट आते हैं। हु यूज़ इट? इसको यूज़ कौन
करता है? इट इज मोस्टली यूज्ड बाय रेड एंड
ब्लू टिमल्स टू प्लान इंप्लीमेंट
औरस्ट्रेट इंगेजमेंट्स बेस्ड ऑन स्पेसिफिक
थ्रेट एक्टर्स और एपीटीज। मतलब यह
फ्रेमवर्क दोनों साइड के प्रोफेशंस के लिए
एक गोल्ड माइन का काम करता है। अगर रेड
टिमर की बात करें, हम इसका यूज करते हैं
टू प्लान इंप्लीमेंट एंड ऑचेस्ट्रेट
इंगेजमेंट्स टू ऑस्ट्रेट आवर इंगेजमेंट्स।
मतलब अगर हम किसी स्पेसिफिक थ्रेट एक्टर
को मिमिक करना है। अगर हमें क्या करना है?
किसी पर्टिकुलर स्पेसिफिक थ्रेट एक्टर को
या किसी पर्टिकुलर
एपीटी को या किसी पर्टिकुलर हैकर्स की को
मेमिक करना है, कॉपी करना है जिसे हम क्या
बोलते हैं? एडवर्सरी एमुलेशन या सिमुलेशन
जिसको हम क्या बोल सकते हैं? एडवर्सरी
एमुलेशन या सिमुलेशन भी बोल सकते हैं। अगर
हमें किसी पर्टिकुलर थ्रेट एक्टर को कॉपी
करना है तो हम क्या करते हैं? हम माइटर
अटैक फ्रेमवर्क से उनका पूरा प्लेबुक
निकाल सकते हैं और उनकी मिमिक कर सकते
हैं। कॉपी कर सकते हैं। सेम टाइप का अटैक
हम भी कर सकते हैं। नाउ बात करें ब्लू
ट्यूमर्स की। इट इज़ आल्सो वैल्यूएबल
रिसोर्स फॉर ब्लू ट्यूमर्स ऐज़ इट प्रोवाइड
द डिटेल्स ऑफ वेरियस टीटीपीस यूज़्ड बाय
स्पेसिफिक थ्रेट एक्टर्स एंड प्रोवाइड्स
कंपनीज़ विद वैल्यूुएबल साइबर थ्रेट
इंटेलिजेंस दैट कैन क्स क्सिक्वेंटली बी
यूज्ड टू इंप्लीमेंट डिफेंसेस और
मिटिगेशंस। इसका मतलब क्या है? कि यह ब्लू
ट्यूमर्स के लिए भी क्या है? एक वैल्यूएबल
साइबर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस का सोर्स है। एक
वैल्यूुएबल साइबर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस का
सोर्स है। रेड टिमर की तो हमने बात कर ली।
यह फ्रेमवर्क ब्लू टिमर्स के लिए भी क्या
है? एक साइबर थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस का सोर्स
है। इससे इससे क्या होता है? इससे उन्हें
पता चल जाता है कि अटैकर्स किस टाइप का
टीटीपीस यूज़ कर रहे हैं। कौन सा टीटीपीस
यूज़ कर रहे हैं। टीटीपीस होता है टैिक्स
टेक्निक एंड प्रोसीजर। किस टाइप की टैिक
टेक्निक्स का वे यूज़ कर रहे हैं उनकी जैसी
सेम ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को टारगेट करने के लिए।
फॉर एग्जांपल्स आप किसी हेल्थ केयर
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में काम कर रहे हो या किसी
पर्टिकुलर ऐसी इंडस्ट्री में काम कर रहे
हो तो उस पर्टिकुलर इंडस्ट्री स्पेसिफिक
उस पर्टिकुलर कंपनी स्पेसिफिक या उस
पर्टिकुलर ऑर्गेनाइजेशन स्पेसिफिक जो
टीटीपीस हैं आप उनको क्या कर सकते हो?
एनालाइज कर सकते हो देख सकते हो। और उसके
अकॉर्डिंग आप क्या कर सकते हो? अपनी कंपनी
में सही सही से डिफेंस और मिटिगेशंस
अप्लाई कर सकते हो। क्योंकि आपको पता है
कि कौन-कौन से टाइप के एपीटी ग्रुप्स हैं
जो आपकी जैसी कंपनियों में इंटरेस्ट रखते
हैं। अगर वह इंटरेस्ट रखते हैं तो किस
टाइप का वो डाटा चुराते हैं। किस टाइप का
वो अटैक परफॉर्म करते हैं? उनकी टेक्निक
क्या होती है और उनके मिटिगेशंस क्या
होंगे? तो हमें किस टाइप का डिफेंसेस और
मिटिगेशंस अप्लाई करने हैं। तो ये सारी
चीजें क्या है? ब्लू ट्यूमर्स को हेल्प
करती है। वहीं पर रेड टमर्स को क्या करती
है? रेड टिमर्स इसके अकॉर्डिंग क्या करते
हैं? उस पर्टिकुलर एपीटीज के अकॉर्डिंग
बिल्कुल उनका अटैक सिमुलेट कर सकते हैं।
उनके अकॉर्डिंग प्लान कर सकते हैं या
बिल्कुल उसकी मिमिक कर सकते हैं।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? अंडरस्टुड?
माइट अटेक फ्रेमवर्क के बारे में समझ में
आया?
अंडरस्टुड
सबको समझ में आया?
यह आपका माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क है। कुछ
इस तरीके का दिखाई देता है। चलिए, हम बात
भी कर लेते हैं माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क के
बारे में।
यह है आपका माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क। ओके?
यहां पर क्लिक करोगे। यह मटर अटैक
फ्रेमवक्स हैं। यह सारी क्या है? टीटीपीस
हैं। जैसे कि आप क्या करोगे? मैं यहां पर
ज़ूम कर देता हूं। यह रहा। तो, यहां पर
देखो मैट्रिक्स है। यहां पर आपको मैट्रसेस
में मोबाइल से रिलेटेड टीटीp देखने को
मिलेंगी। आईसीएस से रिलेटेड या
एंटरप्राइजज़ से रिलेटेड। जैसे एंटरप्राइज
पे क्लिक किया। यहां पर देख सकते हो। जैसे
आपको Windows से रिलेटेड देखना है, Mac OS
से देखना है। जैसे हम Windows से रिलेटेड
टीटीpस देख सकते हैं। एपीटी ग्रुप देख
सकते हैं। उसके बाद देखो टेक्निक है पूरी।
यहां पर देखो इनिशियल एक्सेस है। उसके बाद
एग्जीक्यूशन है, पर्सिस्टेंस है,
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन है, स्टिल्थ है,
डिफेंस है, क्रेडेंशियल एक्सेस है,
डिस्कवरी है, लेटरल मूवमेंट है। चलिए हम
जैसे कि Mac OS पे देखो MS OS से रिलेटेड
ये TTP है, Linux से रिलेटेड है, क्लाउड
से रिलेटेड है। जैसे मोबाइल से रिलेटेड भी
TT टीटीps जैसे Android से रिलेटेड ये रही
और iO से रिलेटेड यह रही। तो, जैसे हम
एंटरप्राइज पे गए। एंटरप्राइज पे हमने
फाइंड आउट किया आपका नॉर्मल। तो सबसे पहले
रिकॉन फेज है। रिकॉन फेज में उसके बाद
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट है। हम रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट की बात करते हैं। तो रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट हमने क्या किया? एक्वायर एक्सेस
पे क्लिक किया। एक्वायर एक्सेस पे क्लिक
किया तो आपने देखा कि ये इसके बारे में
डिस्क्रिप्शन है। बहुत सारी चीज लिखी हुई
है कि एडवर्सरीज में परचेज और अदरवाइज
एक्वायर एंड एकिस्टिंग एक्सेस टू ए टारगेट
सिस्टम और नेटवर्क। उसके बाद ये देखो उनकी
आईडी है। उसके ग्रुप का नाम है।
डिस्क्रिप्शन है। किस टाइप के वो यूज करते
हैं। अदरवाइज हम देखो एक्वायर इनेशन में
एक और चीज है। डोमेनस की बात करी ये रहा।
तो ऐसी बहुत सारी चीजें हैं जो यहां पर
मेंशन की गई है। तो आज ये हमारा
माइट्राटेक फ्रेमवर्क का तो टॉपिक है
नहीं। अदरवाइज इसमें मैं और भी अच्छे से
इसको समझा सकता था। बट आपको बता देता हूं।
जैसे कि हम इसमें और क्या करते हैं?
ओके यह रहा एकवा इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और हम
जाते हैं इसके अंदर कोई है
हम हम
नो जैसे कि हम इसी को ओपन करते हैं एबर
डिियर यह देखो इसमें कुछ है यूएसी ग्रुप
सो यह रहा एक्टिव स्कैनिंग स्कैनिंग तो यह
क्या ब्रूट फ़ यह जैसे पासवर्ड स्प्रेइंग
जैसे यहां पर इसका रिसोर्स देख सकते हो यह
फुल पीडीएफ अवेलेबल इसके ऊपर कि कैसे-कैसे
टेक्निक का यूज़ करते हैं। कौन-कौन से
टेक्निकल डिटेल्स इसमें मेंशन है। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी इंडस्ट्री ट्रैकिंग क्या-क्या
यूज़ करते हैं? कैसे करते हैं? जैसे
टीटीपीस और रिकॉन कैसे करते हैं?
क्या-क्या यूज़ करते हैं? नेक्स्ट देखो
इसमें एमस ड्रॉप स्कैन। यह सारी चीजें देन
यह देखो पूरी डिटेल यहां पर रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट रेदर देन बिल्ड कस्टम सॉल्यूशन
यूनिट 2915 साइबर एक्टर्स यूज़ कॉमन रेट
टीमिंग टेक्निक्स एंड पब्लिकली अवेलेबल
टूल्स टू कंडक्ट साइबर वेपन्स देखो
साइबर एज अ रिजल्ट मेनी टीटीपीस ओवरलैप
विद दोज़ ऑफ अदर साइबर एक्टर्स व्हिच कैन
लीड टू मिसएट्रीब्यूशन यहां पे देखो
अपेंडिक्स व इनिशियल एक्सेस लेटरल मूवमेंट
बहुत सारी चीजें यहां पर मेंशन की गई है।
वेब रिक्वेस्ट ऑब्जर्व फ्रॉम विक्टिम
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर लाइक दैट तो
सब कुछ मिल जाएगा कि कौन सी कंट्री से
ऑपरेट करते हैं। कौन-कौन क्या है मतलब
बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन माइट अटेक फेमवर्क के
बारे में पता चल गया।
जैसे टैक्टिक्स की बात करें इंटरप्राइजेस
ये सारी क्या है आपकी? ये सारी आपकी
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट की
टेक्निक्स है। ठीक है? रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
की टैिक्स है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
समझ में आया?
समझ में आया
बताइए।
चलो फिर अभी बात करते हैं हमारकी
ऑफ टीटीपीज माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
कैटेगराइज एडवर्सियल टेक्निक्स इनू ए
कलेक्शन टैिक्स फदर ऑर्गेनाइज्ड इनू
टैिक्स टेक्निक्स सबटेक्निक्स एंड
प्रोसीजर्स मतलब क्या है कि ये क्या कर
रखे हैं इन्होंने इनको डिवाइड कर रखा है
पहले टैिक्स टैिक्स है टैिक्स को फिर
टेक्निक्स फिर सबटेक्निक्स और प्रोसीजर्स
में डिवाइड किया है जिनको हम टीटीपीस भी
बोलते हैं तो इसको हम क्या करते हैं?
थोड़ा सा और डिटेल में समझते हैं। तो
डिटेल में समझते हैं टीटीपी हरार्की के
बारे में। द माइटर अटैक ब्रेक्स अटैकस
बिहेवियर इनू ए स्ट्रक्चरर्ड हरार्की
कॉल्ड टीटीपीस। जो माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
क्या करता है? जो आपका पूरा अटैकस
बिहेवियर है उसको एक स्ट्रक्चरर्ड हरार्की
में डिवाइड करता है। जिसे हम क्या बोलते
हैं? टीटीपीस। जिसे हम क्या बोलते हैं?
टीटीपीज बोलते हैं। तो सबसे पहले बात करते
हैं किससे? टी से। टी मतलब टैक्टिक्स।
टैक्टिक का मतलब क्या होता है? टैक्टिक
रिप्रेजेंट द एडवर्सरी, टैक्टिकल,
ऑब्जेक्टिव और गोल। जो टैक्टिक्स है वह
रिप्रेजेंट करती है कि जो एडवर्सरी है
उसका टैक्टिकल गोल या ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या है?
ईच मेजर फेजेस ऑफ एन अटैक
मेथोडोलॉजी इज कंसीडर्ड ए टैक्टिक। मतलब
जो अटैक की जितनी भी मेथोडोलॉजी हैं जितनी
भी तरीके हैं उनको उनका हर एक जो मेजर
स्टेप है वो एक टैक्टिक होता है। जैसे
इनिशियल एक्सेस एक टैक्टिक है।
एग्जीक्यूशन एक टैिक्स है। पर्सिस्टेंस
आपका एक टैक्टिक है। मतलब जो भी अटैक
मेथोडोलॉजी है। अटैक मेथोलॉजी में जो भी
मेजर आपके क्या है? जो भी मेजर स्टेप होते
हैं उनको क्या बोला जाता है? एक टैक्टिक
बोला जाता है। बात करते हैं अब टेक्निक्स
की। टेक्निक डिस्क्राइब्स द एक्शन एन
अटैकर यूज टू अचीव ए टेिक। मतलब उस टेिक
को अचीव करने के लिए अटैकर ने किस टाइप का
एक्शन लिया है या क्या एक्शन लिया है वह
कहलाता है आपका टेक्निक। मतलब टैक्टिक
आपको पता है जो भी मेथडोलॉजी है तो मेजर
मेथोलॉजी में जैसे आपका इनिशियल एक्सेस है
या एग्जीक्यूशन है या पर्सिस्टेंस है फॉर
एग्जांपल इनिशियस एक्सेस लेने के लिए
अटैकर ने किस टाइप का एक्शन लिया है जैसे
फिशिंग
फिशिंग ईमेल फिशिंग किया है या विशिंग
किया है या कुछ और तरीका अपनाया है
इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन करने के लिए तो वह
क्या कहलाती है आपकी टेक्निक कहलाती है।
नाउ अभी हम बात करते हैं सब टेक्निक की।
सब टेक्निक भी होती है। सब टेक्निक मतलब
स्पेसिफिक डिटेल्स। सब टेक्निक इनवॉल्व्स
ए मोर स्पेसिफिक इंप्लीमेंटेशन लेवल
डिटेल्स ऑफ हाउ ए टेक्निक इज कैरिड आउट।
मतलब क्या है कि जो सब टेक्निक है वो यह
बताती है कि उस टेक्निक को इंप्लीमेंटेशन
लेवल पर कैसे परफॉर्म किया गया है। टेिक
आपको पता चल गया था। टेक्निक्स क्या है कि
उस टेक्निक को परफॉर्म करने के लिए क्या
एक्शन लेना है? अब सब टेक्निक क्या है कि
जो आपकी टेक्निक्स है उसको इंप्लीमेंट
कैसे करना है वो आपकी क्या कहलाती है? सब
टेक्निक्स। उसको इंप्लीमेंट कैसे करना है?
मतलब आप फिशिंग वाया मशियस अटैचमेंट। एक
एग्जांपल हो गया। मतलब आपने चूज़ किया कि
हम क्या करेंगे? टेक्निक फिशिंग टेक्निक
का यूज़ करेंगे। उसको इंप्लीमेंट कैसे
करेंगे? हम फिशिंग करेंगे। एक मिलसियस
अटैचमेंट के द्वारा हमें क्या करेंगे? एक
अटैचमेंट भेजेंगे। उसके अंदर फिशिंग लिंक
होगा। उससे हम क्या करने वाले हैं?
इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन करने वाले हैं। यह
आपका सब टेक्निक होगी। अब प्रोसीजर की बात
करें। प्रोसीजर शोज़ द एग्जैक्ट स्क्रिप्ट
कमांड और ए टूल ए स्क्रिप्ट एपीटी ए
स्पेसिफिक एपीटी ग्रुप यूज्ड टू
एग्जीक्यूट दैट टेक्निक इन द रियल वर्ल्ड।
मतलब जो प्रोसीजर है, प्रोसीजर हमें यह
बताता है किसी स्पेसिफिक एपीटी ग्रुप ने
इस टेक्निक को एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए कौन
सी एग्जैक्ट स्क्रिप्ट का यूज किया, कौन
सी कमांड का यूज किया या कौन सा टूल रन
किया या उस स्पेसिफिक स्क्रिप्ट का नाम,
वो स्पेसिफिक स्क्रिप्ट या स्पेसिफिक
कमांड या स्पेसिफिक टूल का नाम क्या
कहलाता है? आपका प्रोसीजर के अंदर। आपको
पता चल गया टैक्टिक क्या है? आपका
आपके तरीका टेक्निक क्या है? उस तरीके को
इंप्लीमेंट करने के लिए एक्शन क्या लेने
वाले हो? उसके बाद एक्शन भी आपने सोच
लिया। उसका इंप्लीमेंटेशन आपका क्या
कहलाएगा? सब टेक्निक। अब इंप्लीमेंटेशन
करते वक्त आप या तो स्क्रिप्ट यूज़ करोगे,
कोई ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट यूज़ करोगे, ऑफिस
डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर कोड भी होगा, मशियस
कोड भी होगा, उस कोड को रन करने के लिए
कोई कमांड भी होगी या उसको मॉनिटर करने के
लिए कोई टूल भी होगा। वो सारी चीज किसके
अंदर आ गई? प्रोसीजर के अंदर आ गई। वो
सारी चीज किसके अंदर आ गई? आपकी प्रोसीजर
के अंदर आ गई। इसीलिए द ग्रेटेस्ट
स्ट्रेंथ ऑफ द माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क इज
दैट इट डज़ नॉट स्टॉप एट थ्योरी। इट शोज़
हाउ डिफरेंट एपीटी ग्रुप एक्चुअली
एग्जीक्यूट टेक्निक्स एंड सब टेक्निक्स इन
रियल वर्ल्ड ऑपरेशन। इस फ्रेमवर्क की सबसे
बड़ी खूबसूरत बात यह है कि आपको सिर्फ यह
आपको दिखाता है कि अलग-अलग एपीटीज ग्रुप
इन टेक्निक्स और सब टेक्निक को एक्चुअल
में कैसे एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। यह आपको
प्रैक्टिकली बताता है। आपको ओनली सिर्फ
थ्योरी नहीं है। आपको सब कुछ बताता है कि
यह पर्टिकुलर एपीटी ग्रुप या दूसरा एपीटी
ग्रुप किस टाइप की टेक्निक और सब टेक्निक
का यूज़ करता है। पूरी डिटेल्स में कैसे
वो एग्जीक्यूट करता है। यह सारी चीजें
काफी डेप्थ में किसके अंदर मेंशन रहती है?
माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क के अंदर में रहती
है। तो आई होप सबको समझ में आ गया होगा।
टीटीपीस क्या होती है? टैक्टिक क्या होता
है? टेक्निक क्या होती है? सब टेक्निक
क्या होती है? प्रोसीजर्स क्या होती है?
क्या किसी को इसमें कोई डाउट है? क्या
किसी को इसमें कोई डाउट है?
क्या किसी को इसमें कोई डाउट है?
आगे पढ़ना है या य पर रोकना है बताओ।
क्योंकि अभी तक मैंने रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
की एग्जैक्ट डेफिनेशन नहीं बताई है।
क्या आगे पढ़ना है या नेक्स्ट क्लास में
करना आगे? बताओ।
बाकी लोग
चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं। अभी तक
हमने सब
पढ़ा था कि रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और
वेपनाइजेशन। अब एक्चुअल में रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट होता क्या है? एक्चुअल में
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट होता क्या है? तो चलिए
इसके बारे में हम बात करते हैं रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट के बारे में। तो इन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ रेटिमिंग एंड द माइटर अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट इनवॉल्व्स
गैदरिंग क्रिएटिंग और एक्वायरिंग द
नेसेसरी टूल्स टेक्निक्स एंड नॉलेज टू
एग्जीक्यूट एंड अटैक और पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट
इफेक्टिवली। मतलब सिंपल शब्दों में समझे
तो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का मतलब है अटैक या
पेन टेस्ट को इफेक्टिव इफेक्टिवली
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए जरूरी टूल्स
टेक्निक्स और इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
और नॉलेज को गैदर करना, टूल्स को क्रिएट
करना और एक्वायर करना। मतलब कि किसी भी एक
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट को या किसी भी एक अटैक
को सक्सेसफुली या इफेक्टिवली एग्जीक्यूट
करने के लिए जिन भी टूल्स जिन भी
टेक्निक्स या जिन भी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर या
नॉलेज की रिक्वायर्ड होती है उनको क्या
करना गैदर करना क्रिएट करना या फिर उसको
एक्वायर करना क्या कहलाता है आपका रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट दिस फज़ टिपिकली इनवॉल्व्स
रिसर्चिंग वनेबिलिटीज अंडरस्टैंडिंग द
टारगेट एनवायरमेंट एंड आइडेंटिफाइंग
पोटेंशियल अटैक वेक्टर्स। इस फज़ में क्या
करता है? एक रेड टीमर टारगेट एनवायरमेंट
को समझता है। उसके अंदर वनेबिलिटीज को
फाइंड आउट करता है। देन उसके बाद
पोटेंशियल अटैक वेक्टर्स को आइडेंटिफाई
करता है। एंड रिसोर्सेज कुड इंक्लूड
एक्सप्लइट कोड, कस्टम स्क्रिप्ट, रिकॉन
टूल, सोशल इंजन टैिक्स एंड एनी अदर
एसेट्स। अब रिसोर्सेज क्या-क्या हो सकते
हैं आपके? आपके कस्टम एक्सप्लइट कोड हो
सकते हैं। आपके स्क्रिप्ट हो सकती है।
रिकॉन टूल्स हो सकते हैं। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग टैिक के लिए टेंपरेट हो सकती
है या फिशिंग के लिए डोमेन हो सकते हैं।
या फिर सी टू सर्वर कमांड एंड कंट्रोल
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सेटअप भी आपका रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट का पार्ट हो सकते हैं। बेसिकली
हर वो एसेट जो अटैक के लिए जरूरी है वो
आपका क्या हो सकता है? पार्ट हो सकता है।
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का। द गोल ऑफ रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट इज टू इक्विप द रेड टीम और
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर विद एवरीथिंग दे नीड टू
सक्सेसफुली ब्रीच द टारगेट डिफेंसेस। मतलब
क्या है? रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का गोल है
टारगेट डिफेंसेस को ब्रीच करने के लिए या
सक्सेसफुली ब्रीच करने के लिए जिनजिन
भी चीजों की रिक्वायरमेंट है उनको तैयार
करना। क्या है? रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का गोल
है। चलो फिर एक प्रैक्टिकल
सिनेरियो समझते हैं। तो फॉर एग्जांपल वी
आर प्लानिंग ए क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स एंड
आवर गोल इज टू गेन इनिशियल एक्सेस इनू एन
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेटवर्क बाय टारगेटिंग एन
एंप्लई फॉर एग्जांपल हम क्या कर रहे हैं
मान लो हम एक क्लाइंट साइड अटैक प्लान कर
रहे हैं और हमारा गोल है किसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के नेटवर्क में घुसना
इनिशियल एक्सेस लेना एक एंप्लॉय को टारगेट
करके तो रिकॉन फेज में हमने किया वी
परफॉर्म रिकॉन फाउंड ए टारगेट एंप्लॉय एंड
डिस्कवर्ड दैट वी कैन टारगेट देम यूजिंग ए
फिशिंग ईमेल। हमने रिकॉन किया। एक टारगेट
एंप्लॉय को ढूंढा और हमने पता लगाया कि हम
फिशिंग ईमेल से से उस एंप्लॉय को टारगेट
कर सकते हैं। और हमने थोड़ी सी और
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर की और पता लगाया कि जो
एंप्लॉय है वो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का
यूज़ करता है। उसके पास Microsoft ऑफिस
इंस्टॉल्ड है। और भी अदर उससे रिलेटेड
इनेशन के बारे में हमने क्या किया? पता
लगाया। ड्यूरिंग रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट फेज हम
क्या करेंगे कि आवर जॉब इज टू कन्वर्ट ऑल
दिस इंफॉर्मेशन इनू कॉन्टेक्स्ट। अब
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट फेज में हमारा काम है
इस सारी इंफॉर्मेशन को कॉन्टेक्स्ट में
बदलना। आवर गोल इज टू फुल्ली इक्विप
आवरसेल्व्स। सो वी कैन ब्रीथ द टारगेट
डिफेंसेस। हमारा गोल है खुद को फुल्ली
इक्वि इक्विप करना ताकि टारगेट के
डिफेंसेस को सक्सेसफुली ब्रीच किया जा
सके। और हमारा हम क्या करेंगे? हम क्या
करेंगे? प्रिपेयर ए विंडोज स्पेसिफिक
पेलोड। हम क्या करेंगे? Windows स्पेसिफिक
पेलोड को रेडी करेंगे। परचेस ए डोमेन दैट
लुक्स रिलीचमेंट। हम क्या करेंगे? डोमेन
परचेस करेंगे जो दिखने में बिल्कुल रियल
लगे। क्रिएट ए मशियस माइक्रो डॉक्यूमेंट
टारगेटिंग Microsoft Office। हम एक क्या
करेंगे? Microsoft Office का को टारगेट
करने के लिए एक मिलिश डॉक्यूमेंट क्रिएट
करेंगे। बेसिकली हम क्या कर रहे हैं? वी
आर नॉट फायरिंग द अटैक। वी आर जस्ट
प्रिपेयरिंग आवर एंटायर सेटअप बेस्ड ऑन द
टारगेट एनवायरमेंट। बेसिकली हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? यहां पर कोई अटैक एग्जीक्यूट
नहीं कर रहे। हम बेसिकली टारगेट
एनवायरमेंट के हिसाब से अपना पूरा
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेडी कर रहे हैं। तो
इसलिए माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क क्या करता है?
हमें पूरी दुनिया के जो भी हैकर्स है, जो
भी हैकर्स है, वह जो भी टेक्निक का यूज
करते हैं, उनको एक ऑर्गेनाइज्ड मैप बनाकर
आपको प्रोवाइड करता है। और जिसमें सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट फज़ कौन सा है? माइट अटैक
फ्रेमवर्क में? रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट दूसरा
ही फज़ है। तो इसलिए माइटर अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
में रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट फज़ और भी ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाता है किसी भी सक्सेसफुल
अटैक को परफॉर्म करने के लिए। ठीक है?
क्योंकि जो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट है वह आपकी
वह फंडामेंटल टैक्टिक है जहां हम अटैक
शुरू होने से पहले ही लैब में बैठकर बहुत
सारे टूल्स और इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को असेंबल
करते हैं। उनको वेरीफाई करते हैं। उसके
अकॉर्डिंग हम क्या करते हैं?
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को सेटअप करते हैं टारगेट
एनवायरमेंट के लिए। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन यहां
तक
यह क्लियर है सबको?
यहां तक क्लियर है तो आगे बढ़ते हैं।
थोड़ा सा टॉपिक रह गया फिर तो
नेक्स्ट हमारा टॉपिक आता है साइबर किल
चेन। नेक्स्ट हमारा टॉपिक आता है साइबर
किल चेन। तो अभी हम बात करते हैं एक और
हाईली हाईली पावरफुल और क्लासिक मॉडल की
दैट इज कॉल्ड साइबर किल चेन। द साइबर किल
चेन डेवलप्ड बाय लोकेंट मार्टिन इज ए
फ्रेमवर्क यूज्ड टू डिस्क्राइब द स्टेजेस
ऑफ ए साइबर अटैक फ्रॉम द इनिशियल रिकॉर्न
टू एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन ऑफ डाटा।
इस फ्रेमवर्क को लॉक एंड मार्टिन ने डेवलप
किया था। इसका मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव है एक साइबर
अटैक के पूरी लाइफ साइकिल को स्टेप बाय
स्टेप ट्रैक करना। यानी इनिशियल रिकॉन से
लेकर मतलब इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग से लेकर
डाटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेशन तक एक अटैकर कौन-कौन
सी स्टेजेस से गुजरता है या कौन-कौन सी
स्टेजेस परफॉर्म करता है वो क्या है? इस
फ्रेमवर्क का ऑब्जेक्टिव है। इट कंसिस्ट
ऑफ ए सेवरल सीक्वेंशियल स्टेजेस इज
रिप्रेजेंटिंग ए फज़ दैट एन अटैकर मस्ट गो
थ्रू टू अचीव देयर ऑब्जेक्टिव। यह एक
सीक्वेंशियल फ्रेमवर्क है। सीक्वेंशियल का
मतलब होता है अटैक के सारे स्टेजेस एक
लाइन में एक के बाद एक अरेंज्ड वे में।
मतलब जो आपका साइबर किल चेन है वो क्या
है? आपका एक सीक्वेंशियल फ्रेमवर्क है
जिसमें जितने भी जो टेक्निक्स हैं वह एक
लाइन में अरेंज है। एक के बाद एक परफॉर्म
होती हैं। अगर अटैकर अपना फाइनल
ऑब्जेक्टिव अचीव करना चाहता है या अगर कोई
भी अटैकर अपने फाइनल ऑब्जेक्टिव तक
पहुंचना चाहता है तो उसको क्या करना
पड़ेगा? इन सीक्वेंशियल स्टेजेस से गुजरना
पड़ेगा। इन सारे फेजेस को सक्सेसफुली पास
करना पड़ेगा अपना ऑब्जेक्टिव अचीव करने के
लिए। एंड द रेड टीमिंग ऑफन इनवॉल्व द यूज़
ऑफ साइबर किल चेन फ्रेमवर्क टू सिमुलेट
एंड एक्सेस एन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन डिफेंसिव
कैपेबिलिटीज। और एज ए रेड टीमर हम इस
फ्रेमवर्क का यूज़ करके किसी भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन की डिफेंसिव कैपेबिलिटीज को
सिमुलेट और एक्सेस कर सकते हैं या हम
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को उनकी डिफेंसिव कैपेबिलिटी
को शो करने के लिए इस टाइप का सिमुलेशन
परफॉर्म करके दिखा सकते हैं। ओके? या अगर
आप क्या करना चाहते हो किसी कंपनी की
डिफेंस को चेक करना चाहते हो कि कितनी
स्ट्रांग है कितनी है तो आप क्या कर सकते
हो साइबर किल चेन का यूज कर सकते हो या
साइबर किल चेन को रेप्लिकेट कर सकते हो और
आपकी साइबर किल चेन क्या है यह आपकी साइबर
किल चेन है साइबर किल चेन में टोटल सात
स्टेप होते हैं। सबसे पहला होता है रिकॉन
वेपनाइजेशन
डिलीवरी एक्सप्लॉयटेशन इंस्टॉलेशन कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल एंड एक्शन ऑन ऑब्जेक्टिव और
जैसे कि उसमें आपका माइट्राटेक फ्रेमवर्क
के अंदर सेकंड स्टेज क्या था? स्टेप क्या
था आपका? रिसोर्स एंड डेवलपमेंट। वहीं पर
वेपनाइजेशन यहां पर क्या है? सेकंड स्टेज
है। मतलब यह क्या? सबसे पहले आपने क्या
किया? रिकॉन किया। उसके बाद कपलिंग
एक्सप्लइट विद बैक डोर्स इनू डिलीवरीबल पे
लोड। बिल्कुल बहुत ही माइनर डिफरेंस है बट
डिफरेंस है। लेकिन अननोइंगली अनजाने में
हम दोनों हम इन दोनों को सेम ही समझते
हैं। लेकिन दोनों अलग-अलग
मॉडल से आए हैं। अलग-अलग फ्रेमवर्क से आए
हैं। लेकिन एक के बाद एक यूज़ होते हैं।
वेपनाइजेशन पहले रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट आता
है। उसके बाद वेपनाइजेशन आता है। और जैसा
कि मैंने आपको बताया कि रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
क्या होता है? अभी मैं आपको बताऊं
वेपनाइजेशन क्या होता है? नाउ वेपनाइजेशन।
तो वेपनाइजेशन इज द प्रोसेस ऑफ टेकिंग द
रिसोर्स डेवलप्ड इन द प्रीवियस फेज एंड
कन्वर्टिंग देम इंटू एक्चुअल वेपन्स दैट
कैन बी यूज्ड टू एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज एंड
कॉम्प्रोमाइज द टारगेट सिस्टम। सिंपल
शब्दों में समझे तो वेपनाइजेशन एक ऐसा
प्रोसेस है जहां आप अपने रॉ रिसोर्सेज और
टूल्स को एक्टिव वेपन में कन्वर्ट करते
हो। प्रीवियस स्टेजेस में आपने जो भी कुछ
रेडी किया था उनको क्या करते हो? एक्टिव
स्टेट में कन्वर्ट करने के लिए वेपनाइजेशन
का यूज करते हैं। बेसिकली वी कैन से दैट
कि हमने क्या किया? एक क्लैप में मिसाइल
को तैयार किया। मिसाइल में गोला बाड़ू सब
कुछ उसके अंदर प्लांट कर दिया। उसके अंदर
जो भी कुछ एक्सप्लोजिव सब कुछ प्लांट करके
अरेंज रख दिया। लेकिन उसको एक्टिव करने के
लिए फ्यूज नहीं लगाया। फ्यूज कौन लगाता
है? वेपनाइजेशन। जब फ्यूज लगाया दिया तब
वह फायर करने के लिए रेडी है। फ्यूज को
निकाल लिया। उससे पहले सारा काम रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट में हुआ। फाइनल रेडी है। बस एक
फ्यूज लगाना है उसको एक्टिवेट करने के लिए
और फायर करने के लिए। तो वो फ्यूज का काम
क्या करता है आपका? वेपनाइजेशन करता है।
दिस फेज इनवॉल्व्स क्रिएटिंग पेलोड्स,
क्रिएटिंग मिलसियस फाइल्स, कॉन्फ़िगरिंग
एक्सप्लइट कोड टू डिलीवर द इंटेंडेड
इंपैक्ट सच एज गेनिंग अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस
एक्स फिल्ट्रेटिंग डेटा और डिसरप्टिंग
सर्विसेस। अब इस फेस में बेसिकली क्या
होता है? आपका पेलोड क्राफ्टिंग। हम कस्टम
पेलोड बनाते हैं। मिशियस फाइल क्रिएशन।
मिलसियस फाइल क्रिएशन ऐसे फाइल्स जनरेट
करते हैं जो टारगेट पर डिलीवर होंगे। उसके
बाद क्या करते हैं? कॉन्फ़िगरिंग एक्सप्लइट
कोड। उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं?
एक्सप्लइट कोड को टारगेट सिस्टम की
आर्किटेक्चर के हिसाब से मॉडिफाई करते हैं
ताकि आपको अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस मिल सके या
आप डाटा एक्स फिल्ट्रेट कर सको। आप अन
ऑथराइज एक्सेस लेस को या फिर डाटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेट कर सको या फिर आप उनकी सर्विज
को डिस्टर्ब कर सको। नाउ वेपनाइजेशन ऑफन
इनवॉल्व्स कंबाइनिंग वेरियस टेक्निक्स और
टूल्स इन ए वे दैट मैक्सिमाइज देयर
इफेक्टिवनेस व्हाइल मिनिमाइजिंग द रिस्क
ऑफ डिटेक्शन।
जो वेपनाइजेशन का सिंपल रूल है अलग-अलग
टूल्स और इवेज टेक्निक्स को इस तरह से
कंबाइन करना। कि अटैक सबसे ज्यादा
इफेक्टिव हो और डिफेंसिव सिस्टम उसे
डिटेक्ट ना कर पाए। मतलब अलग-अलग टूल्स का
यूज करना, अलग-अलग इवेजिव टेक्निक का यूज़
करना और उनको यूज़ करके कंबाइन करना,
कंबाइन करना ताकि जो अटैक आप परफॉर्म कर
रहे हो, उसका जो इफेक्ट हो, वह सबसे
ज्यादा हो और जो डिफेंसिव सिस्टम्स हैं,
जाके एंटीवायरस एडीएस हैं, उसको डिटेक्ट
ना कर पाए। यह इसका मेन गोल होता है, मेन
रूल होता है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन समझ में आ गया कि
रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट एंड वेपनाइजेशन क्या होता है?
चलो लास्ट।
अब समझते हैं रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट वर्सेस
वेपनाइजेशन।
ठीक है? अब आते हैं आपके सवाल पर जो आपके
मन में होगा या आना चाहिए था कि सर माइटर
अटैक के रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट और साइबर किल
चेन के वेपनाइजेशन इन दोनों में एक्चुअल
डिफरेंस क्या है सर? अगर मुझे किसी को
एक्सप्लेन करना हो तो सर इन दोनों में
एक्चुअल डिफरेंस क्या है? तो चलिए इसके
बारे में बात करते हैं। सबसे पहले बात
करते हैं इन टर्म्स ऑफ़ फोकस। रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट फोकसेस ऑन एक्वायरिंग द नेसेसरी
टूल्स एंड नॉलेज वेयर एज वेपनाइजेशन
फोकसेस ऑन टर्निंग दोज़ रिसोर्सेज इनू
एक्टिव अटैक पेलोड्स और टेक्निक्स
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का पूरा फोकस होता है
टूल्स इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और नॉलेज को
एक्वायर करना इकट्ठा करना और वहीं पर जो
वेपनाइजेशनंस है वेपनाइजेशन का फ़ फ़ोकस
होता है उनको को एक्टिव अटैक पेलोड्स या
डिलीवरी वेक्टर्स में बदलना। जो भी आपने
टूल्स इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर या जो भी नॉलेज
आपने गैदर करनी की है उनको क्या करना?
जो आपकी इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर्स है टारगेट
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर्स है उन पर अटैक करने के
लिए क्या करना?
डिलीवरी के लिए रेडी करना या उनका पेलोड
में कन्वर्ट करना। जैसे मैंने बताया क्या?
मिसाइल में फ्यूज का काम करना। जैसे
फेसिंग ईमेल के साथ अटैचमेंट
चिपकाना क्या है? किसका काम है?
वेपनाइजेशन का। फेसिंग ईमेल आपने रेडी कर
ली। बस उसके अंदर क्या करना? अटैचमेंट
लगाना। उसके बाद उसको रेडी करना। फाइनल
एग्जीक्यूशन स्टेप के लिए। वो क्या है?
आपका वेपनाइजेशन है। अब बात करते हैं
स्टेजेस इन अटैक लाइफ साइकिल। रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट टिपिकली प्रोसीड्स वेपनाइजेशन।
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट हमेशा पहला स्टेप होता
है वेपनाइजेशन से। वंस द नेसेसरी
रिसोर्सेज आर डेवलप दे आर देन वेपनाइज्ड
फॉर यूज़ इन द अटैक। जब आपके पास सारे रो
रिसोर्सेज रेडी हो जाते हैं, तभी आप
उन्हें अगले स्टेप में लेके जाकर वेपनाइज
कर सकते हो। जब तक आपके पास रिसोर्सेज
रेडी नहीं होंगे, तब तक आप उन्हें वेपनाइज
नहीं कर सकते। नेचर ऑफ एक्टिविटीज की बात
करें। रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट एक्टिविटीज मे
इंक्लूड रिसर्च, रिकॉन एंड टूल डेवलपमेंट।
जो रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट में क्या आता है?
वनेबिलिटीज को फाइंड आउट करना, टूल्स
डिप्लॉय करना, कमांड एंड कंट्रोल्स,
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर बिल्ड करना एटसेट्रा।
वहीं पर वेपनाइजेशन इनवॉल्व्स, क्रिएटिंग,
क्फ़िगरिंग अटैक पेलोड्स, क्राफ्टिंग
मिलसियस फाइल्स, प्रिपेयरिंग एक्सप्लइट
कर। वहीं पर जो वेपनाइजेशन क्या है उसमें
क्या करता है? फाइनल पे लोड कॉन्फ़िगर
करना, मिलिशियस फाइल्स क्राफ्ट करना और
एक्सप्लइट कोड को स्टेबल फॉर्म में
कन्वर्ट करना, प्रिपेयर करना आपका किसके
अंदर आता है? वेपनाइजेशन के अंदर। अब
आउटपुट की बात करें कि दोनों का आउटपुट
क्या मिलता है? रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
आउटपुट्स, टूल्स, नॉलेज एंड इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट द टारगेट एनवायरमेंट। अब जो रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट का आउटपुट होता है वह टूल्स और
सर्वर का इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और टारगेट की
नॉलेज। टारगेट के बारे में ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इन नॉलेज इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के बारे
में नॉलेज और टूल्स के बारे में नॉलेज।
एंड वेपनाइजेशन आउटपुट्स एक्चुअल अटैक
पेलोड्स और टेक्निक्स रेडी फॉर
डिप्लॉयमेंट। और वेपनाइजेशन का आउटपुट
होता है एक एक्चुअल फुल्ली फंक्शनल अटैक
पेलोड जो टारगेट पर डिप्लॉय होने के लिए
बिल्कुल रेडी है। मतलब एक फुल्ली फंक्शनल
पेलोड जो अभी आप उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर दो तो
वह टारगेट पर एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा। वह
होता है आपका वेपनाइजेशन का आउटपुट। सबको
बिल्कुल क्लियर है अभी रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट
और वेपनाइजेशन एक्चुअल में होता क्या है?
क्लियर है?
तो आप एक अपडेटेड मेथोलॉजी का यूज़ कर सकते
हो। दैट इज एडप्टेड क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
मेथोलॉजी स्ट्रक्चरर्ड अप्रोच प्लानिंग टू
एग्जीक्यूटिंग क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। मतलब
जो हमने पढ़ा उन दोनों को मिलाकर अगर हम
एक नए से अलग सी मेथोलॉजी तैयार करें तो
यह हो सकती है सबसे पहले प्लानिंग। सबसे
पहले प्लानिंग में आता है आपका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रिकॉर्न।
उसके उसके बाद आपका आता है एक्शनबल इंटरनल
में आपका रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट।
पेलोड डिप्लॉय मेंट में आता है आपका
वेपनाइजेशन और वेपनाइज पेलोड आपका आ गया
डिलीवरी। तो रिकॉन की बात करें गैदर
इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
सिस्टम नेटवर्क एंड पोटेंशियल
वनेरेबिलिटीज व पर रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट में
एक्वायर एंड डेवलप द नेसेसरी टूल्स नॉलेज
एंड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर टू कंडक्ट सिमुलेटेड
अटैक वेपन प्रिपेयर द एक्वायर्ड और डेवलप
रिसोर्सेज फॉर यूज इन द सिमुलेटेड अटैक
नेक्स्ट उसके बाद डिलीवर द वेपनाइज्ड
पेलोड और सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टैिक टू
इनिशिएट द अटैक अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन
सबको क्लियर है?
मजा आया सेशन में या नहीं आया?
जो लोग मिस करते हैं तो मिस करते ही रह
जाएंगे क्लासेस को।
मजा आया?
कोई डाउट है क्लास से रिलेटेड?
पीपीटी ऐप में अभी अपडेट नहीं हुआ। मैं सर
को दे दिया था पीपीटी लास्ट
ऐप चेक किया।
एप्लीकेशन चेक किया जिसमें मे बी आपने ₹40
में ज्वाइन किया था।
दोनों फ्रेमवर्क का अलग-अलग पर्पस है
ब्रो। जो माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क है उसका
पर्पस था कि सारा डाटा कलेक्ट करके एक जगह
पर रखना। लेकिन जो माइट्रा अटैक फ्रेमवर्क
है वो आपका एक्चुअल एग्जीक्यूशन स्टेप
एग्जीक्यूशन अटैक है कि स्टेप बाय स्टेप
जैसे मैंने आपको बताया ना कि स्टेप वन
होना, स्टेप टू, स्टेप थ्री हर एक
सक्सेसफुल अटैक करने के लिए सारे स्टेप को
फॉलो करना। इसलिए अलग-अलग बनाए गए हैं।
उसका पर्पज अलग है। इसका पर्पज अलग है।
लेकिन हम दोनों को मिक्स करके यूज़ करते
हैं। क्योंकि उसने स्टेज टू को रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट बोला है। इन्होंने स्टेज टू को
बोला है वेपनाइजेशन। लेकिन बिल्कुल एक थिन
लाइन जितना इनमें डिफरेंस है क्योंकि काम
दोनों सेम ही कर रहे हैं।
बताओ चेक करके बताओ जल्दी से क्योंकि
लास्ट में क्लास में बोल सारे आपके क्लास
60 से लेके 60 सॉरी 70 तक 71 तक के नोट्स
को हमने क्या किया उसमें वो किया है।
अपडेट किया है। पूरी हाई क्वालिटी नोट्स।
मीडियम में यार लिख तो दूं नहीं है। पता
क्या है? प्रॉब्लम क्या है? मुझे टाइम
नहीं मिलता। सच बता रहा हूं। क्योंकि मेरे
पास कोई लिखने के लिए नहीं है। और मुझे
टाइम नहीं मिलता मीडियम पर ये आर्टिकल
लिखने का।
इसलिए नहीं लिख पाया मैं क्योंकि मैंने
क्लासेस 60 से ले कितनी 10 12 क्ला। इनको
मैं लिखने का टाइम नहीं है क्योंकि अभी आज
के बाद मुझे नेक्स्ट आपके सैटरडे संडे के
लिए लेक्चर रेडी करना है और नेक्स्ट से हम
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं।
नहीं हुआ अभी तक
मैं फिर से बोलता हूं सर को। ठीक है। मैं
सर को फिर से बोलता हूं। और
किस में Windows फंडामेंटल तक है?
क्या पूछना चाह रहे हो?
किस में फंडामेंटल तक की बात कर रहे हो?
नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं ऐसा नहीं है। बहुत
सारी चीजें अभी आई नहीं है। Windows
फंडामेंटल कवर करने के बाद Windows के
एक्सप्लइटेशन
थोड़ा सा हुआ है। प्रिज एस्केलेशन लेटरल
मूवमेंट दोनों चीज बची हुई है। Linux और
Windows
अभी Windows देखो आपके
प्रिलिज एस्केलेशन लेटरल मूवमेंट दोनों पर
क्लासेस होनी है। बहुत सारी क्लासेस
आएंगी। यह खत्म होते ही आपका मैं थोड़ा सा
वेब का कवर वेब के कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
इंपोर्टेंट जो वनविटी जैसे ऑथेंटिकेशन
अटैक हो गया। बहुत सारे जो एक्सटर्नल पेन
टेस्टिंग के अंदर आते हैं इंपॉर्टेंट
इंपोर्टेंट उनको कवर करूंगा। उसके बाद फिर
हम प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन नेचर मूवमेंट पे
आएंगे। डेफिनेटली आएंगे। अभी हम फ्लो में
चल रहे हैं ना। अच्छा फ्लो है ना? अभी
सबको पसंद आ रहा है फ्लो?
हां हां डे 33 के बाद मेरे क्या है कुछ
थोड़ा सा इधर एरर हो रखी है आपके नोट्स
में वो मुझे पूरे रीजनरेट करने पड़ेंगे
उसके लिए मुझे थोड़ा समय चाहिए बाकी 60 से
मेरे पास पूरे आपके नोट्स अलग से पीडीएफ
डाउनलोड हो रखे हैं वह तो मैं ऑलरेडी भेज
चुका हूं
नहीं बिल्कुल क्लियर है। देखो
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट वेपनाइजेशन बिल्कुल
पासपास में रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट क्या है कि
आपने जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट की है फॉर
एग्जांपल हम इसका एग्जांपल लेते हैं सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के लिए। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
लिए आपने टारगेट सिलेक्शन किया। टारगेट
सिलेक्शन करने के बाद आपको लगा कि मैं इस
पे क्या कर सकता हूं? मुझे फिशिंग कर सकता
हूं। आपने सेलेक्ट कर लिया। फिशिंग कर
सकता हूं। तो फिशिंग करने के लिए आपको
क्या करना पड़ेंगे? रिसोर्सेज डेवलप करने
पड़ेंगे। मतलब फिशिंग आप कैसे-कैसे कर
सकते हो? फेसिंग के लिए आपको क्या चाहिए?
एक तो आपको डोमेन चाहिए।
ईमेल सर्वर चाहिए। उसके बाद फिशिंग में आप
क्या यूज़ करना चाहते हो? वेबसाइट आप कोई
लिंक भेजोगे तो वेबसाइट का लिंक भेजोगे।
कोई पेमेंट का लिंक भेजोगे, क्यूआर कोड
भेजोगे तो उसको सेटअप करने के लिए आपके
पास सेटअप चाहिए। उसका इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
आईडी चाहिए। ये सारी चीजें किसके अंदर है?
आपके रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट में। क्योंकि जब
फिशिंग के लिए आप एक पेज भी डिजाइन करोगे,
किसी वेबसाइट का आप क्लोनिंग भी करोगे या
उसका पर्टिकुलर पेज आप डिजाइन करो, सारी
चीज़ का रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट का पार्ट आ गया।
यह सारी चीज़ आपने क्या कर ली? आपने एक
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेडी कर ली। ओके?
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर रेडी होने के बाद क्या
करना है कि अब टारगेट है टारगेट के लिए
टारगेट का आपने क्या किया फॉर एग्जांपल आप
उसको भेजना है तो भेजना अब भेजने के लिए
आप किस चीज का यूज़ करोगे किस मीडियम का
यूज़ करोगे जैसे कि आपने फेसिंग ईमेल में
अच्छे से एक पीडीएफ यूज़ करोगे ठीक है
पीडीएफ में आपका कि सो ऑन सो यह आपकी
सैलरी स्लिप है यह एंड आप इस पे आपकी एक
बार क्रॉस चेक कर लीजिए तो जैसे पीडीएफ
डाउनलोड होगी
तो पीडीएफ में के अंदर आपने क्या किया? एक
पेलोड अटैच कर दिया। तो पेलोड अटैच कर
दिया। तो आपने वेपनाइजेशन में क्या किया?
आपने उसको पैक कर दिया। मतलब पीडीएफ के
साथ आपके पेलोड को पैक करके रख दिया। अब
फाइनल चीज क्या बच गई? डिलीवरी। डिलीवरी
करते ही वह एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा। तो मतलब
रिसोर्सेज के लिए आपने पूरा सेटअप कर दिया
और उस पूरे सेटअप को आपको पैक करना है। एक
मतलब डिलीवरी के लिए रेडी करना है। वो
आपका वेपनाइजेशन स्टेट है। जैसे मैंने
एग्जांपल लिया था। फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे कि
आप किसी भी कोई भी अ साइंटिस्ट है। फॉर
किसी ने मिसाइल बनाया। मिसाइल में बहुत
सारी चीजें होती हैं। उन्होंने क्या किया?
उसके अंदर पेलोड लगाया। पेलोड हेड लगाया।
उसके अंदर रेडार बहुत सारी चीजें उन्होंने
क्या की? उसके अंदर सेटअप की बहुत सारे
इलेक्ट्रॉनिक्स आइटम ले बहुत कुछ किया
पूरा रेडी कर दिया बस एक चीज छोड़ दी उसके
अंदर फ्यूज नहीं लगाया क्योंकि बिना किसी
फ्यूज के वो एक्सप्ललोड नहीं कर सकती वो
ट्रैवल नहीं कर सकती मतलब ल्च नहीं हो
सकती तो पूरी मिसाइल रेडी कर दी कवर में
पैक कर दी उसके अंदर एक्सप्लोसिव डाल दिया
उसको एक्टिवेट कर दिया जो कोड करना था कोड
कर दिया जो चीज उसके अंदर फिक्स करनी थी
सब कुछ फिक्स करके रख दी फाइनल में एक
फ्यूज की जगह छोड़ दी उस फ्यूज को जैसे ही
लगाओगे तो वह क्या है एक्टिव है डिलीवरी
के लिए भी हायर होने के लिए भी तो फ्यूज
क्या है आपका वेपनाइजेशन है अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन अभी समझ में आ गया
यस डिजाइन उसको रेडी करना आपका डिजाइन और
उसको रेडी करना इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को उसके
लिए सेटअप करना
उसके बाद फाइनल पैकिंग कौन करेगा
वेपनाइजेशन
ओके
और कुछ किसी को कोई डाउट है
कोई डाउट है तो बताइए। अदरवाइज सेशन को
एंड करते हैं और नेक्स्ट सेशन से हम
स्टार्ट करने जा रहे हैं।
यह टेक्निकल प्रॉब्लम है। मतलब कि यह चीज
ब्रो मैं नहीं देखता मतलब पीसी लॉग इन
नहीं होता है। तो यह चीज मैं नहीं देखता
बिकॉज़ यह चीज देखते हैं नितेश सर। तो जो
हेल्पलाइन नंबर अपना डेफोनिक
इस पर आपको बता देता हूं।
एकडमी जैसे क्लिक करोगे यहां पर आपको यह
रहा या तो ईमेल कर दो या पर कॉल कर लो वो
आपको फिक्स कर देंगे आपकी चीजों को ओके
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। मैं यह
बता रहा था नेक्स्ट क्लास स्टार्ट हो रही
है आपकी मै डेवलपमेंट से। मैक्रोस के बारे
में सिखाऊंगा कैसे उसको उसको लिखा जाता
है। ओके? मै डेवलपमेंट
नेक्स्ट क्लास।
डोंट मिस द नेक्स्ट क्लास। जितनी भी
क्लासेस आने वाली है अभी भी। ओके? तो चलो
फिर बाय-ब एवरीवन एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन। सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन।